[Music]
this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist i got
my co-host check nice jack hey hey neil
all right all right you know it's time
we do yet another installment we've done
some very interesting installments on
kovid yes and it's progress right it's
how our reactions to exactly like the
fact that you know it doesn't exist
we did we did the show about how it was
a hoax and that's it
did i think we did that show about how
vaccines kill people um no no we did the
one that with the with the mike the the
oh the microchips yeah
the microchip
i love the 5g show that we did
there could be first-time listeners
chuck i don't want to mess with you we
shouldn't do that
you know there's i think of it as a you
know the computers have a cloud that
sort of thing right there's an academic
cloud
where in that cloud you kind of you
reach in so there's an academic who's
got expertise i want right you pull them
out of the cloud you know talk to them
for a business stick them back in the
until i think about this you know
honestly the way you're describing this
makes it sound like you're
sound like you're killing scientists
no no no
no it's worse not the spirit energy yeah
it's worse it's like they're descending
from heaven or something yeah well yes
exactly exactly so we got nick
christakis nick welcome to star talk
and i i found you i was listening to
somebody else's podcast and i said damn
i want him on my podcast as i got all
selfish about it so uh you're a
professor up at yale and you're a
trained sociologist with also extensive
medical background and what a perfect
combination of pedigree to talk about
covid19
and societal reactions to it this is
exactly the stuff you think about and
care about and do
and your recent book was just released
in paperback apollo's arrow and give me
the subtitle on that again
uh the profound and enduring impact of
coronavirus on the way we live
nailed it so nailed it
he got he got it right yeah he got there
you go by the way he wrote this before
long before we were where we are right
now so
when people were saying that this was
going to last for three weeks he was
writing this book
he's saying no it's not i got it right
here right here check it out
so so nicholas just want to say upfront
that my father was a sociologist and i
have very deep respect for all those who
work in that field and i think they're
under-heralded in what role they can
play do play should play and what
insights they have that the rest of us
don't so i'm delighted to have you on
star talk so so nicholas uh in your book
apollo's arrow in the in the preface you
describe
the fact that
this pandemic and the social reaction to
it is playing out as you'd expect
so what does that mean what did you know
that the rest of us didn't
and
does that mean we're just the same as
every previous pandemic that we read
about in the history books or did we do
a little better
no we didn't do any better unfortunately
you would think that in the 21st century
we would have done better
uh i think there are two
benchmarks you can use a one benchmark
is uh respiratory pandemics
we have records of those going back
about 300 years and very detailed
records going back a hundred years or
more generally plagues which have been
afflicting human beings for thousands of
years
and
a plague is not just a general term for
a really bad epidemic or does it have
specific referencing to like what it
does to your skin or your or other parts
or other organs well plague i would say
is the broader category to a respiratory
pandemic so they're non-respiratory
plagues right there are as you said
afflictions of the skin or afflictions
of the gastrointestinal tract for
example or neurologically like polio for
example
uh or hiv you know is a plague uh but it
doesn't uh primarily manifest itself in
respiratory uh other than pneumocystis
pneumonia in respiration the one thing
they all have in common is that they are
judgments from god
okay so some so some
so some would believe in fact but see
here's here's here's the interesting
thing that that you guys are
highlighting which is that
is that this way we've come to live in
uh in 2021 and 2020 2021 now going to
2022 seems so alien and unnatural but
actually it's neither of those things
plagues are a part of the human
experience uh plagues are plagues are in
the bible they're in homer's iliad one
of the canonical works of western
fiction begins with a plague they're in
shakespeare they're in cervantes so so
plagues are not new to the human
condition
they're just new to us
we think this is crazy that we have to
live in this way and that we're facing
this this threat but this threat is an
ancient threat that our ancestors
confronted in fact they were so alarmed
and disturbed our ancestors were by
their experience that they reduced this
experience into our religious traditions
into our literary traditions they they
tried to warn us our ancestors tried to
warn us they said there's this thing
that happens it's a plague it's awful uh
and let's tell you about it and and we
we somehow didn't listen to them we
didn't we didn't hear it and many of my
jewish friends for example in uh in the
spring of 2020 uh during passover you
know they were like all my life i'd said
the passover seder and now suddenly you
know i was i really understood what my
ancestors were talking about when they
talked about a plague
so
so this is a very you know we have
written records of plagues going back
thousands of years many of the things
that we are experiencing i would say
almost all of them frankly
are familiar um
thucydides in the plague except for the
5g except except for the 5g well
yes but i don't know i don't know i've
read some things about bubonic where
they were like hey
5g
well no almost guys almost literally
almost okay so in fact during the plague
of justinian fifteen hundred years ago
uh i'm pretty sure it was a plague of
justinia it was one of the wait wait you
have plagues just wait you just have
plagues memorized he's just you just you
just plague fluent let me just tell you
i am that's obvious
at the same time dr christakis has a
plague catalog in his head
there are many
there are many plagues
yes but but the 5g analogy so one of the
things is so in my lab we study we study
um
sorry let me let me announce that yeah
so you're you're a director i'll say it
for you director of the human nature lab
at the yale institute for network
science so this is this is where
where the rubber hits the road so go on
yeah all right well we study the
mathematical architecture of human
social networks the evolutionary origin
of networks why do we have friends why
why our human networks have a particular
topology a particular structure how did
natural selection shape that structure
what does it mean for our lives and and
and how are we equipped to
interact and so on so we study all of
these things and then we study spreading
processes on what are called these
graphs these architectures of ties so we
study for example how germs spread or
how ideas spread or how uh how uh money
spreads or how emotions spread and how
all of these things spread within
networks and what we're talking about
now this is sort of very abstract but
what we're talking about right now is
the spread not only of the germ the the
coronavirus in our case but also you
highlighted this 5g you know conspiracy
theory the misinformation how it spreads
and one of the things you need to
understand about plagues going back
thousands of years
is that as the germ spreads through this
social network right behind it is lies
and in fact this has been observed for
thousands of years so during the plague
of justinian i think
uh i think it was john of ephesus who
was a historian and a priest at the time
and was documenting what was happening
he has this very kind of almost funny
passage where he says you know the
plague was devastating the city
and a rumor went out such that the
housewives in the city uh concluded that
if you threw terra cotta pots out the
second story window of your house onto
the street below and it's shattered uh
this would uh ward off the plague and so
john of ephesus writes he goes it became
more dangerous to walk through the city
for fear of being hit by pots right than
for than from from contracting the
plague itself
so so so these types of superstitions we
saw them you know
from the white house in the last
administration you know that if you
inject yourself with bleach or or
irradiate yourself or or charlatans of
all kinds appeared out of the woodwork
saying take silver or do this or do that
or all kinds of rumors as you said neil
about 5g
and on and on about vaccination about
masking okay
actual thing is just a detail
it's the idea that a that misinformation
follows a social networking pattern no
matter what that misinformation except
for the bleach except for the bleach
the bleach works it works no it's very
good very good
i'm sorry sorry
the two general principles neil and uh
one general principle is that
is that you might almost say that the
emergence of mendacity
is uh is a feature of plagues that in
other words even to call something a
plague you might might want to go so far
as to say not only do we need a
spreading and serious pathogen not only
do we need rising case counts which by
the way is the synoquinone of an
epidemic
but we also need lies
you that's one principle the second
principle is that you can model the
spreading dynamics the the ways in which
this information spreads on the graph
similarly that you model the spread of
germs that's the second overarching
principle
but the details are of course different
right like what is the const what is the
rumor is it 5g is that uh is it that
what is the piece of misinformation that
of course varies uh from play to play
yeah
oh man i just want to know
based on what you just said
is any of that um
can you can you
measure and quantify
who does that purposely because i'm sure
there are opportunists who know that and
take advantage of it
you know you often see demagogues rise
at the same time that's exactly right in
fact you um often serious pandemics lead
to great shifts in the political
landscape or are prompted by prior
shifts in the political landscape for
example if there are wars or conflict
between states often you see plagues
arise then and after plagues you can see
uh people despots and others rise to
power exploiting the suffering of people
but one of the things that's also very
interesting and this borrows on some
metaphors from physics
you can think of
a a social network which many listeners
just to be clear but we can we can back
up just for a moment so
when you say that a despot would exploit
the
the underclass or
but what i think what you mean there
correct me if i'm wrong is that if
you've been
if you're if you've been badly affected
by the plague whatever previous system
of governance
did not prevent it
so it allows someone else to rise up and
claim
that they're going to be the one to fix
it for you
yes and there's so much that's how
you're taking advantage of this is that
how you feel yes even in other words it
sometimes it's it's explicit like some
some some desperate says i'm going to
deliberately exploit this uh others it's
not so explicit it's just a change in
social order so for example after the
bubonic plague
in the 14th century in europe and by the
way the bubonic plague the black death
called yeah the black death so-called
which was in um 1340s
there were waves of it every every few
decades for 500 years in europe and it
it decimated the european population
uh there are many people who have argued
correctly in my view that that kind of
death where let's say about 30 percent
of europeans died in some cities 50 or
80 or 90 percent of the residents of a
city died
led to a great crisis so it was very
clear the politicians couldn't stop it
so those guys were useless the priests
couldn't stop it so religion was useless
the doctors and the scientists didn't
know what was going on so they were
useless so many people have argued that
it gave rise it paved the way for the
emergence of new democratic institutions
politically new forms of government new
types of science uh and the reformation
that it paved the way for a different
attitude towards religion so all of
those things are
are things that can happen but if i
might i wanted to go back to what i was
going to say on these spreading
processes which was a different aspect
of what chuck asked which is that
social networks if many people are
familiar with these images of networks
with dots and lines drawn on a
two-dimensional page
uh
you know this complexity with this sort
of knot in the middle and this kind of
feathering towards the edges but
actually networks are a hyperdimensional
surface
and you can think of things spreading in
that surface so for example the germ is
spreading you can think of waves of
germs in that surface
and waves of information in that surface
and you can actually borrow mathematics
from physics to look at wave
interference and so the question is
which wave like how do they reinforce
each other so a wave of misinformation
you see can reinforce a wave of the
spread of the germ
or vice versa a wave of the spread of
the germ can activate people to seek out
accurate information and you can borrow
certain kind of mathematics involving
differential equations and other ideas
to model these these uh wave
interference pattern and you can
actually in my lab does this kind of
work you can actually get a deeper
understanding of how these things
interact and the circumstances under
which waves of information can [ __ ]
waves of correct information can [ __ ]
the spread of the germ and waves of
misinformation can accelerate the spread
of the germ
so this is a i mean in wave mechanics if
if two waves are resonant with peaks and
valleys matched up then they they
basically double the effect yes they can
come out of phase with each other and
then cancel yeah so you're you're
applying this to social networks this is
this is this is great so the
constructive interference of social
networks yes yes yes wow yes
so we got to take a break but when we
come back
nicholas
i'm tired of hearing you tell me
what the problem is i'm going to know
what the solution is okay that's why i
have you on this show okay let's start
we'll
see what stark talk returns
we've got profession
good stock is talking about the social
networks
and kovit
we're back star talk i've got nicholas
christakis he is a professor at yale who
thinks about and studies social networks
even before the thing is social networks
was a common term
because there have been social networks
even before the internet believe it or
not and so when you've got that kind of
insight that millennials
i know you've got some deep
understanding of what's going on how and
why
so we left off uh nicholas with you
describing a hyper-dimensional
coordinate system where
where information
true or false moves
in this coordinate system and
occasionally interferes with other
movement of information cancel out or
magnifying it and i love that analogy to
the physics of the wave mechanics what i
want to know is
what good are you
to have this analysis if you can't in
the next breath say here's what you do
about it
well we do a lot of experiments in my
lab to try to exploit a deep
understanding of human social
interactions and of the mathematics and
dynamics of human social networks
to try to invent things to make the
world better now if i might i'll just
digress and just sketch a couple of
experiments and then
some potential implications with respect
to the coronavirus pandemic
so for example
one of the things we do is we we use
some software we've developed to map
networks in developing world villages
for example in india in uganda and in
honduras where we have a big a project
funded by a number of funders including
the gates foundation and the nomas
foundation we mapped the networks of
people there using this software we ask
people who are your friends and we ask
everyone else who are their friends we
map these networks and then we use some
mathematical algorithms to identify
who in the individual who in this
village let's say is structurally
influential
not by virtue of who they are how rich
or poor or tall or short for example
they are but rather by virtue of where
they are located within the network for
example if you were a bioterrorist then
i asked you who in new york city would
you want to infect to get the biggest
epidemic the fastest possible you might
imagine that someone very popular and
very well connected in the city would be
the person you would infect rather than
someone who has no friends for example
and just stays alone in their apartment
so so
but we can use more sophisticated
methods than that and then you can
identify people within these villages
and then you can give them an
educational intervention for example
about breastfeeding or vaccinating their
children or about proper latrine usage
all these public health things that my
lab does
and then what we do is we do these
large-scale experiments where we
randomly assign out of hundreds of
villages different villages to different
targeting algorithms and then we test
which algorithm gives you the biggest
informational cascade can we create
artificial tipping points by
thoughtfully targeting a small subset of
people such that if we persuade them to
change their behavior everyone copies
them so that's one class of experiments
that that makes complete sense in
retrospect of course duh yeah just
describe fox news
well
yeah no that's a joke that's a different
i know but that's a different type of
that's a different kind of broadcast
power in other words one of the things
about networks you have to understand is
is that
is that neil has the same network power
that you and i have chuck in other words
when he likes a book he can tell his
friends whether they like a book or and
and will have some influence on them
just the way i do but in addition he has
like apollo for example for example but
neil also said
for example but yeah
but but neil also has broadcast power
and that's like different than you and
me in that in that that is a rain from
the heavens in other words it's a it's a
kind of uh a different process it's sort
of outside the network system but okay
so that's one class of experiment a
different class of experiment is um
these online experiments we do which
we've done with tens of thousands of
people
where we we create temporary artificial
societies of real people we bring in
let's say 4 000 people and we put them
into 200 groups and we experimentally
manipulate for example the structure of
the groups or the income inequality of
the groups or who is given what piece of
information
who is told the truth and who is lied to
for instance and then we let the people
interact in that system and and then
experimentally test different
interventions that might for example
enhance the cooperation of the system or
decrease the racism for example how how
people treat each other or how we might
optimize the flow of accurate
information in the system so we do all
of these experiments so it's this class
of work that we do that sheds some light
on some interventions we might deploy
with respect to coronavirus but it is in
fact so i can say in the last two two
and a half years you've failed
yeah
i alone yes i i have been unable
it is your fault yes
yes yes yes yes
i mean
yes you know it is it is a difficult
problem in our
enormous society with our media
landscape yes to um
to try to tackle the problem of the
spread of misinformation a huge problem
and
in some ways it also reflects some of
appealing qualities you know we have a
free and open press we we have freedom
of speech in our society i i wouldn't
want to live in a society in which some
agent like the government or some other
agent specified who could say what or
what was the truth but the downside of
that is we have to tolerate
and willfully counteract
the spread of lies and we haven't had
unfortunately a tremendous
a tremendous spread of lies and if i
might just go on a little digression a
more sociological digression
this virus in my judgment
happened to strike us at a particularly
vulnerable moment
in our life as a as a society we we have
a century high levels of economic
inequality
we have half century high levels of
political polarization
we have uh a kind of scientific
illiteracy that i know you and others
are trying to counteract that is it very
high i mean very large fractions of
americans believe in uh that the earth
was created 10 000 years ago for example
or uh don't understand basic statistics
even basic ideas uh we have as well a
kind of um
kind of suspicion of scientists like
because there's a very ascendant
anti-elitism in our society right now
because of this political and economic
polarization scientists are seen as just
another elite another group of people
seeking to exploit us for their own
venal interests which is wrong of course
of course scientists are human they have
their own interests but but that's not
in my judgment the correct way to see
scientists and finally
we have a loss of capacity for nuance in
our society right now everything is
black or white uh you're with me or
you're against me there's a kind of
tribalism and a kind of lack of capacity
to see well things are complicated a lot
of these topics that like climate change
or pandemics or uh or nuclear power or
all of these things that you talk about
are
difficult topics that require a serious
conversation and you know what the virus
struck us right now when we are unable
to work together to develop a basis of
facts and then to fight our ideological
battles apart from the facts and then
once we fight that battle reach a
consensus as a nation on how to combat
the pathogen so we've been we've died
we've died in great numbers neil and
chuck we have died in great numbers
rising through 5 million worldwide right
worldwide but in the united states we
will lose a million americans 2 million
would have died if we'd done nothing i
believe but a million of our fellow
citizens i think at least will have died
before this pandemic is over
partly for our lack of ability to have a
sound scientifically based
politically organized response it's
funny while you were while you were
talking there nicholas chuck was saying
yes yeah just like in church when you
say amen
i was like this preach brother preach
look at the man yes
say it now say it
[Music]
i heard you chuck yeah every 30 seconds
you know why because this listen i love
and you do this too neil and so i i
can't do it and i swear i'm trying
because my exposure because of neil
causes people to you know ask me stuff
and i'm like don't ask me that [ __ ] i'm
sorry
but what i like about you guys and many
scientists
is that everything that dr christoph has
just said
and i've seen this from you too neil
is when you're a comedian
that person is just stupid
that's the way you look at them you're a
dumbass and that's all there is to it
but you guys look at people like no
that's not the way to look at it what we
have to do is figure out how to get
through to that person what we have to
do is figure out how do we inspire that
person and you know i admire that and i
hate it at the same time well also also
chuck i mean the other thing is it's
it's it's a fact that
you know our fates are tied to our
fellow citizens
and so we have a selfish interest in
trying to get our fellow citizens to
behave better
but even if we didn't have a selfish
selfish interest we should have an
altruistic interest i mean these people
who have some of these beliefs in like
5g for example
uh
deserve our care and our help and our
empathy they are our fellow citizens
i have no interest in like right now
there's a kind of uh uh a narrative
that's rising like if you're not
vaccinated you deserve to die i don't
think that's true yeah that's the way i
don't think that yeah it's really rough
i don't think that's true
for several reasons i don't think that's
true first of all i don't think that's
true because i don't want any human
being to lose their life needlessly and
uh and second some of those people
have been taken in
by a set of false beliefs
and have been deluded in a way duped and
and yeah duped and i you know i feel
sorry for them i mean
anyway so this is you know i i think i
i'm very ashamed of how we've done as a
country in terms of combating the plague
i mean we opened this conversation by
talking about how plague is an ancient
threat but the thing that's a little
different about us right now candidly
is we're the richest nation the world
has ever seen
we have 200 years of efforts to invent
vaccines countless scientists doctors
and patients have labored to produce
this knowledge we have
scientific experts we have virologists
immunologists epidemiologists medical
historians who could have told you
about respiratory pandemics going back a
hundred years in fact one of the reasons
i knew this was going to be so serious
is that i knew the history of
respiratory diseases because other
scholars had put them into books and you
could you could by by february of 2020 i
knew what was going to happen you asked
me earlier how did i know well because i
read books you know and there are other
scientists that have spent their lives
studying this stuff so why do we have
nicholas if you read books you're
missing out on some really good video
games
mean but the point is this is this
capacity
this capacity actually there are great
video games about about uh epidemics too
it turns out
but as you guys know this capacity to
the scientific method which is one of
the triumphs of human ingenuity
uh what and and this capacity to collect
information and transmit it which by the
way we spend billions of dollars every
year on in our society in our time of
need
when we were being beset by a deadly
pathogen you would think we would say
aha
we can now take advantage of this and
save our lives and yet a significant
fraction of people and a significant
will didn't do it i'll say one more
thing
i think the intermediate lethality of
this pathogen is 10 times deadlier than
the flu but it's not as deadly as
smallpox or bubonic plague or cholera
which can kill 30 or 50 percent of the
people they infect
this intermediate lethality harmed us i
think if this plague had been let's say
much deadlier and there are
coronaviruses which kill 10 or even 30
percent of the people they infect
i think we would have taken it much more
seriously so
so this this virus was really sneaky you
know it hit us right and this capacity
of the virus this virus has this other
property which is really interesting it
it has what is called protein
manifestations in other words the virus
causes a great variety of clinical
presentations it can affect your lungs
your your gastrointestinal tract your
can make you fatigued and a great
variety of severity so let me give you a
thought experiment
imagine you had a thousand people in
population a has a thousand people
10 of them are infected with a virus and
become seriously ill and one of them
dies
so 10 case fatality rate
now imagine population b
you have a thousand people
10 of them get infected and become
seriously ill and one of them dies just
like before but in addition 90 people
get a mild version of the virus so 100
total people infected in population b
so 1 out of 100 dies 1 fatality rate
so if you ask people which of these two
worlds would you rather be in a world in
which ten percent of the people get
infected die or a world in which one
percent of the people that get infected
die many people would wrongly
choose world b where one percent of the
infected people die but that is a
delusion
if you stop and think about it world b
is the worst world to be in because the
same number of people get seriously ill
the same number of people died but in
addition 90 get a mild illness there's
more disutility in world b world b is a
worse world and this virus not only that
isn't it
not only that isn't it true had it been
more deadly
than and we sort of set to attention
sooner
we
a
a more deadly virus probably would have
ended up with fewer deaths in total it
could have been if we sat to attention
that's absolutely correct we could model
that out right but it's not just that
lethality it's this protean
manifestations because what happened to
us is that many people could say well i
have lots of friends who just had a mild
case so i'm not going to pay attention
so it seems wrongly so it seems less
serious because you have these people
who recover yes or who who have a mild
course exactly
so really what we need
is a virus that is quite demonstrable in
it's not just lethality if people
recover it's like they went through some
like ebola where you see people bleeding
from every single orifice and then they
die and then you're like oh man i don't
want no parts of that yes okay but then
the virus is is less likely to be
transmitted if you're so effective
that's right i mean this this is
nicholas's point right if you if you
have a if if the virus can fool
90 of the population
into thinking it's nothing really
serious right while it kills the others
that it is right
the virus is is happening it's spreading
it's happening
oh my god the virus
is like that dude at the nightclub that
tells every woman something different so
that he can go home with a different
woman every night could be i'm not sure
i would make that that's the exact
analogy here chuck we're going for okay
wait before we end this segment nicholas
could you just tell tell me
what
impact
uh everybody being forced to stay home
had on civilization
now in my community of astrophysics
surely yourself as well
you know it's really not a thing
it's not it's we didn't lose a beat
having to work at home just with a good
internet connection i'm i'm fine but
school children
um other workplace challenges that that
have assembly lines you can't do that
from home what was the net
outcome of this
well i mean i
i like to think of pandemics as having
three phases respiratory pandemics
there's the immediate phase
and we are approaching the end of that
right now so we're not at the beginning
of the end of the pandemic
but we are approaching the end of the
beginning
the immediate phase goes up until 2022.
said winston churchill by the way yes
but a different thing
yeah about a different thing about a
different thing exactly i got to flesh
that out so it was after d-day
and it looked like the allies were
encroaching on the axis forces and the
reporter asked winston churchill is this
the beginning of the end
and he says no but it is the end of the
beginning
yes
exactly if i remember correctly yeah so
that's the i was exactly that language i
was aping neil but
but what you need to understand is is
that right now we are we are we are
being hit with this biological and
epidemiological wave of the virus that's
spreading through this immunologically
naive human population and the virus is
going to spread and spread and spread
and spread among us in our country and
ult and frankly it has to in the in the
whole world until we reach this
important threshold known as herd
immunity basically unless you're a
hermit on the mountains or very lucky
everyone on the planet will either be
infected with this virus or get
vaccinated or both so that's going to
happen we're going to cross that
threshold soon in this country
and then we're finally going to put the
epidemiological and biological impact of
the virus behind us
this does not mean the virus is gone the
virus will still kill people it's not
eradicated but at greatly reduced
numbers it'll fall into the background
welter of things that kill us but then
we will enter the intermediate phase of
the virus
it's like a tsunami has washed ashore
and devastated the countryside the
waters finally recede which is great but
now we have to clean up the mess and
it's that mess that you were alluding to
we're gonna have to cope with the
clinical social economic and
psychological aftershocks of all of this
death and isolation and so on all of
this disruption millions of kids miss
school millions of people will be
grieving the loss of a loved one
millions of people lost their jobs
millions of businesses closed we're
borrowing trillions of dollars against
the future to kind of cope with the
president we're gonna have to pay those
debts and that's gonna take a couple of
years i think until 2024 where we're
going to have this kind of stuttering
emergence from the shock and then i
think beginning in 2024 it's going to be
a little bit of a party kind of like the
roaring 20s of the 21st century
similar to the roaring 20s of the 20th
century after the last major respiratory
pandemic the 1918 uh influenza pandemic
of a hundred years ago well there you go
here's to a terrific 2024 people
happy new year flappers and everything
and
yes i i think yes i think it'll not it
won't be exactly those things but it's
going to be
it's going to be people are going to be
like a release like any human population
that survives a war or an earthquake or
a hurricane or a plague the survivors
are going to be relieved and i think
they're going to have been cooped up
uh they're going to have been socially
isolated i think there there's going to
be a kind of a celebration a kind of
return an exuberant
over correction a kind of return to
enormously and i think people will
relentlessly seek out social
interactions and nightclubs and
restaurants and sporting events and
political rallies going back i think
we're gonna see a lot of political
ferment uh and people will be spending
their money you know we've been saving
our money during this pandemic as people
have for all past plagues so so yes i
think it's going to be quite a um
quite a shift in our society honestly
well we got to take another break but
when we come back yeah i want to further
probe
the emergence from this portal
right this portal that's on the horizon
and what the future society will look
like and will we carry this memory are
we going to have to turn it into
mythologies and legends to carry it for
the next
for our great grandchildren so they
don't go through what we went through or
does it does it the same all over again
when we come back on star talk
we're back star talk
third out of three sentence we're
talking about the sociology of kobit
what it has done to us as a civilization
and we've got our guest from uh up at
yale uh new haven connecticut nicholas
christakis
and uh nick what nicholas how do people
find you in social media or elsewhere oh
i'm on twitter at n a christakis and
then my lab is
humannaturelab.net
so christoph is c-h-i-r-r-i-s-t
a-k-i-s n-a-s
n-a-c-h-r-i-s-t-a-k-i-s yes on twitter
stockist yeah okay so nicholas what a
what of the fact
that the coronavirus is so
varied
in its incarnations
that
is there any hope it will ever end at
all you spoke of herd immunity isn't
that for just one strain but not another
and if if another strain another
mutation is different enough doesn't
that throw all of our immunizations out
the window and we got to start this all
over again
well there are different sorts of ways
that these types of plagues end
um they have a biological end and a
social end
uh the biological end they're actually
different types of biological ends one
biological end we talked about this
notion of herd immunity when enough
people herd immunity is the idea that a
group of people can be immune to a
condition even if not every constituent
individual is immune so for example if
you vaccinate 96 percent of the
population against measles
if one of the four percent unvaccinated
people happens to get a case somehow
they don't create an outbreak because
they're surrounded by immune people and
that percentage that 96 percentage is
the herd immunity threshold and it's
actually given by a little mathematical
formula that connects it to the
intrinsic spreadability of the pathogen
so pathogens that spread more easily you
need higher numbers actually the
spreadability of a pathogen is
quantified by something known as the
basic reproduction number
the r sub zero the r naught and the
formula for computing the herd immunity
threshold is r naught minus one divided
by r naught so for the original strain
of the virus the uh the r naught was
three
three minus one divided by three means
that sixty-seven percent of the
population has have had to have acquired
immunity one way or the other by
vaccination ideally or naturally through
infection before we reach the herd
immunity threshold now i'm not gonna go
so measles is famously spreadable that
would have a correspondingly higher or
not right yeah that's exactly right so
the r knot for measles is like it's the
most spreadable it's like 16 or 18. so
18 minus 1 divided by 18 gets you a
number that's like 96 percent
but before you go any further as the
only non-scientists here let me just
tell those of you who are listening
what dr christakis is saying is we are
not at heard immunity okay
yes
well because the delta the delta variant
chuck has an r naught of six
so six minus one divided by six gets you
eighty-three percent and so and the
omicron variance so let's get we give me
all three so the original one whatever
one that was yeah was that emergen
immunity level uh well it was
about 20 20. it was about three and uh
and so it's it's heard immunity
threshold was about 67 now let me just
just quickly say for some listeners who
might know it turns out this is a simple
arithmetic
calculation if you take into account
network structure and the fact that
people vary in how many connections they
have it actually brings that number down
a little but that's not really relevant
for our conversation right now
these other strains can be more more
spreadable and can have
and are more spread
we don't know they are not for sure yet
it's everybody's got marmicron now
everybody yeah but coming down with it
yeah you don't have it you're not cool
man
i do not want to encourage people to get
infected i know i shouldn't even joke
like that
well not even joke like that no you can
i'll be that's but uh but that'd be
that's because you're chalk
uh but uh no but seriously so we don't
know exactly what the intrinsic are not
of the pathogen is the reason omicron is
so effective is it has a second property
which is its capacity for immune escape
in other words it can re-infect people
who were previously immunized
either by infection or by vaccination
which is a different property either way
however we're getting lots of cases but
here's the thing
you asked me about how pandemics end one
way they end is that enough people
get immunized either through vaccination
or through infection that finally the
the germ runs out of places it can go
a second way
may be what's happening with omicron and
i actually discussed this in apollo 0
which is that there's this
tendency it's theorized and often seen
but it's hard to prove
a tendency of pathogens to become more
benign with time so another biological
end which is likely to be the case is
that
this pathogen will mutate to become less
deadly
which may be happening with omicron so
in other words
if you think about it as you mentioned
earlier neil if the virus infects me and
thickens me quickly and kills me
that variant of the virus
dies with me yeah
but if the virus gives me a mild illness
and doesn't put me in bed and i'm out
and about spreading it those variants of
the virus come to be ascendant they are
more fit from a darwinian point of view
so they will spread more and so what
happens with the time is that the
more spreadable less deadly variants of
the virus on average in general it is
theorized
tend to come to predominate
so so that's the second way that we get
to a biological end so if the mild
version is ascendant then
does that mean ultimately it will think
of it as the common cold yes or the flu
yes and i think that's what's going to
happen and in fact i as i argue i think
that's probably what happened in 1890
there was a so-called russian flu that
many people think was influenza but some
other people speculate myself included
it might have been the last great
coronavirus pandemic the 1890 russian
flu
might actually been coronavirus and now
the virus it may be the case that a
coronavirus that causes the common cold
something called oc-43
may actually be the distant echo of that
what was then a very serious respiratory
pandemic a hundred years ago more than a
hundred years ago
so that's the second kind of biological
end the third biological end
is that over great stretches of time
thousands of years of course we evolve
to deal with a virus so for example many
humans have adaptations against malaria
against
against tuberculosis against other
pathogens that have been around for a
long time because those of us that are
vulnerable die and don't reproduce as
effectively and other humans with
different mutations
survive now that's not going to be the
case in our lifetimes that's over long
eons
but
in addition to the biological ends that
we've been discussing just now there are
also social ends and the social end of
the pandemic is when basically when
people say
you know what
we're just going to accept this
and
and and i think that's beginning to
happen in our society where people are
saying
uh they are kind of
yes something like that and that can
define you see a social end of the
pandemic even if the germ is still going
about its business
at some point humans may um may declare
victory or put their head in the sand uh
and however you want to see it and and
that will mark the social end of the
pandemic
oh
i gotta tell you
none of those sound good
i know right
is it too soon now to begin a social
pandemic i would say so i mean i i know
people are
you know one of the metaphors i use is
i don't have terrific teeth
unfortunately when i was in greece there
was no as a boy there was no florida in
the water so i've had many root canals i
don't know if you guys have or maybe
some of your listeners have had root
canals but they're awful my teeth are
are basically never had a problem
the trade-off is the government doesn't
control your brain now there was no
fluoride in the water
well i wish they'd been struggling
it's all read up on this stuff yes
exactly
all the conspiracy theories is a go-to
guy no but but the thing is the thing
about a root canal is that your being in
the dentist chair and wishing the root
canal to end
has no bearing on whether you need a
root canal in other words yes
you you just you need the root canal and
you're not wanting it has absolutely
nothing to do with and that's the same
with the virus our desires about the
virus
are irrelevant to the virus the virus is
another feature of the natural world it
has its own destiny there's debate about
whether viruses are living or not that's
a topic for another conversation but for
the sake of argument it's acting like
any other living thing it is it is
having what is known in evolutionary
biology as an ecological release it's
like when we accidentally release rats
onto an isolated pacific island and they
overrun the place this virus is
overrunning us it's just spreading and
spreading and spreading in us it's found
untapped terrain and it's just gonna
have its way with us so our desires have
nothing to do with what happens
unfortunately to the virus but we can
we can
uh
develop a kind of social modus vivendi
with a virus we can just sort of say
well you know we're just you know we've
had enough now i think neil it is too
early for us to do that i think we if we
behave better we can still reduce the
toll of mortality in our society i think
that the simplest thing we can do is to
be vaccinated
we are we can get boosted for the
existing boosters but what is also going
to be on the horizon is the
pharmaceutical companies are are going
to release new boosters for new variants
which i would encourage listeners to get
when they come out just like you got
your annual flu shot or you got your
tetanus shot every 10 years
we're going to have these other booster
shots which it will make sense to get
and i think we need to recognize that
this mrna vaccine technology that we
have
is mind-boggling
it it is going to change the future
of how human beings how our species
responds to pandemic disease because we
now have a technology that will allow us
to rapidly prototype and develop
bespoke vaccines against novel pathogens
so that the period of time under which
we must suffer either the social
withdrawal or the death will be reduced
and i think
i think that is a feature one thing that
has been different about this pandemic
compared to all the ancestral ones and
will also be different uh with respect
to future pandemics science to the
rescue
yes but of course nicholas there because
the vaccines
would develop so quickly
became a reason for people
to
distrust them i know they usually they
use that fact against the vaccine i know
rather than be delighted yes in how
quickly
so what you're a sociologist like
explain that well also also before you
explain that you might because in your
book you talk about the fact that uh the
mixed messaging on mask was also yes a
very bad thing yes i think that i think
that there's going to be a reckoning and
i think that
that many scientists um
you know i mean there are many different
sciences of human enterprise of course
and people vary in their beliefs they
vary in their
ability to collect facts they vary in
the facts that they've gathered
themselves different experimenters come
do different experiments they they vary
in their um analysis of the body of
facts they come to different conclusions
this is to be expected and i think one
of the things that's very important to
to explain to listeners is that when
scientists disagree
that's a feature not a bug of science
right that's how science progresses it's
theology where there's no disagreement
ostensibly right like scientists
disagreeing with each other is how the
process works
and um and we test our ideas against the
truth we test our ideas against the
natural world uh and that's part of the
process so the disagreement itself we
could have done a better job preparing
the public to see that scientists might
for example disagree about masking
but very quickly we're going to do
experiments and we're going to come to
some consensus
so that would have been helpful
now on the um
on the speed with which the vaccines
were invented it's true that they were
invented quickly
but now the experiment's been done
hundreds of millions of people have been
vaccinated the vaccines are incredibly
safe we have dozens and dozens of
studies that show that they are also
effective not just in the original
randomized trials but now in large scale
epidemiological studies and it's built
on 200 years of science i mean what what
why were we doing this for 200 years
developing these vaccines develop you
know beginning with cop pox being used
for smallpox so no it's not the case
that you know that we're doing some kind
of creepy experiment with the world
population releasing completely unknown
technologies that that's not and even if
we were even if that were the case which
it is not it is not but even if it were
it worked
all right just yes just look at this it
worked people
my nephew won't get vaccinated for
whatever reason i keep trying to cajole
him into doing it but i said to him bro
i'm your guinea pig i did it for you i'm
fine yes sure you might have relatives
that are anti-vaxxers i do i have
actually more than one i have two
nephews who are anti-vaxxers
and they're young what i don't
understand is
they're young and they don't want to
have any part of it they're also kind of
conspiracy theorists as well
so you know by the way both of you
nephews know who you are i know you
listen to this podcast i'm not using
your name right now but i could call you
out and i'm not calling you stupid but
at any minute
so nicholas i want to try to end on a
positive note isn't that any demographic
shift in respect for science as you go
to the younger generation
i don't know the answer to that i'm sure
there are the answers known i'm sure
there's polls many of them are leading
the the many of them are leading the
climate change initiatives yes so i
think it's an open question i i think if
you put if you force me to pick i think
that
the the demonstration of the power of
science
during this pandemic for example
through the invention of the mrna
vaccine for instance which i think
ultimately will become widely
acknowledged
and the fact that there were many
scientists who were correctly calling
what was going to happen during this
pandemic
may increase public confidence in
science with respect to other global
catastrophes i taught a course at yale
last semester on global catastrophes
with bill nordhaus the famous economist
who won the nobel prize uh for his work
on climate change
name dropping uh yeah exactly
all my friends have nobel peace prizes
chuck you got to get you you got to get
you one get you one chuck get you a
nobel laureate
i was on a podcast with neil degrasse
tyson how about that
no but but i mentioned it only because
his people may not know who he is but
just to mention his credentials anyway
we taught a class on global catastrophes
and you can think of the the coronavirus
pandemic as a kind of accelerated
version of the challenge we were going
to face with climate change you know
that
we have to rely on each other it affects
the whole globe there's a role of
science there's a disputation about what
to do about what's happening all of
these features there's risk tolerance
who should tolerate what risk and at
which generation all of these features
that are features of the climate change
debate and conversation i think are
our features of the how the world is
working on coronavirus and by the way
the the the international collaboration
that will be required to detect and
respond to future pandemics
just just by the way
we get respiratory pandemics every 10 or
20 years there was for example one in
2009 the h1n1 influenza pandemic but
nobody remembers it because it just gave
you the sniffles we get serious
respiratory pandemics every 50 or 100
years we mentioned the 1918 pandemic
there was also a 1957 pandemic which
killed 110 000 americans which would be
220 000 americans today so this one
we're having is the second worst one
we've had in 100 years
we're going to have more pandemics in
the future and there's some scientific
evidence that the inter-pandemic
interval is shortening so we could get
another one in five years and 10 years
and 20 years and 30 years we don't know
when it's going to happen
but it's clear to me that we're going to
need some kind of international system
for monitoring the emergence of these
new pathogens and responding as a as a
global population to it and that system
also
is going to be analogous to the kinds of
systems we need to deal with climate
change so there are many ways in which
the coronavirus pandemic is analogous to
this other global catastrophe that's on
the horizon and i think it's got to
cross our bowel
across our bowel and i think that young
and i think that young people may see
the utility of science
may have seen it in their own lives with
respect to the coronavirus pandemic and
therefore neil come to also apply it as
you suggested to other challenges so i
hope inshallah as they say i hope that
uh that that we will have a more
sober-minded
more pragmatic and more
respectful i'm not going to say
deferential but respectful attitude
towards the utility of science in our
society which one more thing
is actually the root of our wealth and
security like one of the things that one
of the things that's hilarious to me is
people use this device which was
invented by scientists and engineers
actually you can trace this device back
to faraday in 19th century you know in
england
and uh they use it to say oh these
scientists don't know what they're
talking about i mean
for those of for those of you who are
just listening dr christopher's is
holding up a smartphone yes a smartphone
of course yes yes yes yes and and uh we
got to land this plane but here's a
quote that i saw on a poster during the
science march
um
first one of the posters said
you know things are really bad when
scientists have to march
that was the first time
that was that's a great poster
but another one was
uh what do we want a time machine when
do we want it it doesn't matter that's
my other second favorite
but third favorite was every disaster
movie begins
yes with a person in power ignoring the
warnings of a scientist
every single one of you yes well
nicholas this has been a delight thank
you for giving of your time and we need
you to go back and teach your class with
all your nobel laureates oh stop it i'm
gonna go back
i'm gonna go back to my lab i'm gonna go
back to my lab
but thanks for coming on on relatively
short notice because i only you only
came to i knew of you from previous
years but just to have you as a relevant
to anything i'm doing that was only the
last few days thanks for your fast
turnaround thank you so much thank you
both for having me it's been a pleasure
it's all right all right chuck always
good to have you here man always a
pleasure
all right next i'm going to call out
your nephews all right we'll please do
i'm telling you
they may actually do something if neil
degrasse tyson calls them out actually
but seriously your nephews what they
need to understand is
is that
death is a problem of the aged
uh in general in other words young
people face a very low risk of death
from all causes but coronavirus
increases your nephew's risk of death by
about 30 percent
in other words there they have their
young people they have a one in a
thousand or one in
uh
probably a one in five thousand chance
in dying in the next year
but coronavirus might increase that to
uh 1.3 in a thousand now they may think
oh absolutely that's trivial but that's
actually a really substantial increased
risk of death you know and and anyway
i'm that's the conversation i have with
my the young people in my extended
family uh that's good
listen they're they're listening right
now they listen so they're they're all
right so you must be fun at the dinner
table
[Laughter]
this has been star talk another covid
installment catching up with what it's
doing and where it's going where it came
from i'm neil degrasse tyson your
personal astrophysicist
keep looking up
[Music]
you